if you think today's games don't feature
nearly enough child punching then you'll
be happy to know that ps2 classic bully
has just been released on ps4 I'm Kate
and this is you're my dad could take
your dad news update bully and manhunt
to rockstar classics from the
playstation 2 era have been unexpectedly
released on the playstation 4 both
titles upscaled to 1080p and have been
retrofitted with trophy support and are
available on the store for 11 pounds 99
or 14 euro 99 each they are currently
only available in Europe but could show
up in North America through the next
scheduled PlayStation Store update
originally released in 2006 bully cast
players as Jimmy Hopkins a teenage
miscreant has been dumped by parents at
Bulworth Academy a school ruled by
cliques and corrupt teachers Jimmy must
overcome the trials and tribulations of
high school to rise to the top of the
food chain manhunt meanwhile was
released in 2003 and in the years
following was the subject of much
controversy the Rockstar North developed
title mixed the psychological thriller
genre with stealth action and horror
players take on the role of James L cash
a death row prisoner who finds himself
as the subject of a snuff film he has
promised his freedom but under the
condition that he's able to survive a
city full of brutal gang members out to
get him did you play either game back
when they came out or will you be trying
them out now could the surprise release
of to rockstar games mean that Red Dead
Redemption will finally come to the
current generation of consoles let me
know in the comments all come and find
me on Twitter I'm at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
game spot